in the firing line
for an eighth consecutive night but
attacks on police were contained to one
or two interfaces
with young people doing most of the
rioting it was always going to be
difficult
to restore calm in belfast
prayers on the pace line catholic and
protestant church leaders stood
together in opposition to the street
violence tearing communities apart
in flashpoint areas these signs were
erected
loyalist leaders calling for the
postponement of protests
as a mark of respect young activists
like mur homes
regard themselves as the most loyal
subjects of the crime
the loyalist community and many within
are angry at the northern ireland
protocol and that's
completely understandable and completely
justified but i think
there is a mood within the loyalist
community this evening that tonight is
not a night for protest
it's a night for morning it's a night to
pay respect
and to pay homage to an incredible
individual tributes from unionists are
one thing from republicans another
altogether
forty years after the ira murdered lord
mountbatten prince philip's uncle
sinn feinberg respects to the royal
family so i want to um
offer my condolences to the queen
elizabeth
in regards to the death of her husband
also to all those people
in this community who come from the
english tradition or indeed have a
british identity i want to again extend
my condolences to all you because i'm
quite sure
that you've felt this loss more
significantly maybe perhaps than others
it comes in a week when police deployed
water cannon against rioters here for
the first time in six years
northern ireland has witnessed the worst
violence in a long time
as tension over the brexit protocol
reached a boiling point
at a time when loyalists feel their
british identity is under threat
not to mention the status of northern
ireland as part of the united kingdom
a conciliatory statement on the death of
prince philip from the leader of
republicanism at stormont is hugely
significant
on both sides there are those
acknowledging the duke of edinburgh's
interest in northern ireland he visited
56 times
given the queen's own role in peace
building here the death of her husband
provides a moment for all to reflect
david blevins sky news in belfast